modère ses termes vous savez que
matthieu delormeau avait fait une
couleur on lui avait promis un 8,33
matthieu delormeau et benoît revenez moi
je venais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors venez venez vous ne vous êtes pas
maintenant alors quand droit s'est
occupé de votre couleur vous vouliez à
8,33 j'ai juste et la base il manque la
mèche à mèche d'accord comme un art et
j'y tiens c'est un 8 on doit donc c'est
un blond un blond vénitien
ah non pas du tout voilà californien
californie d'accord qu'est ce que c'est
que ça alors celle là là parce que
j'aimerais bien peaufiné d'accord vous
avez vos fines et alors il ne va pas
devoir tout de suite d'accord
est ce que vous voulez alors d'abord je
ne veux pas que mathieu se voit enlever
tout parce que vous allez avoir la
surprise je pense que je vois il ya du
bon sens mais la maladresse de bienvenue
aller à celui ci ça fait ressortir si
j'ai fait confiance alors les chéris
couper tous les retours s'il vous plaît
et si vous pouviez remercie pouvez vous
vous calmez vous plaît merci
attention alors vous allez donc mes
chéris ouais vous allez refaire donc la
coiffure de mathieu oui bien sûr j'ai à
travailler au doigt un peu là stylisé
d'accord voulait à styliser sais pas
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'il ya
attends mais mai à bâle mais jamais ses
jumeaux n'est jamais vous n'êtes pas
coiffée et juste la base et les
politiques mais est ce qu'on veut mais
ça mais je préfère ainsi dans sunshine
bien sûr aussi vert sencha je ferai tout
ce que tu veux chanter my way semag
régine non mais pas les deux tu es
artiste capillaire go alors on va hyper
bien ou mathieu mathieu aubert bien je
vous jure c'est vrai c'est ma gueule ah
oui près de m haies en partant en
vacances en thaïlande
mais s'il vous plaît vous partez en
vacances en thaïlande oui ça va plaire
aux thaïlandais ça mais moi j'ai qu'une
question c'est est-ce que ça vous plaît
ah ouais et n'oubliez pas que c'est pas
terminé il a fait la base de blond
j'adorerais faire du mesh jamais chance
il dort sunshine juste après après
l'émission il a peaufiné parce que le
manga 100 m haies alors été les mêmes ce
que je propose c'est qu'on va remettre
la serviette
d'accord mais vous allez vous découvrir
derrière le miroir et vous allez me dire
ce que vous en pensez
moi je trouve ça magnifique film écrase
tout merci est resté ce mois guy bouliez
d'accord belle et la motion non mais je
vais rire m'inquiète qui n'a pas fait
une connerie tu me mets tu vois bien les
côtés idiot regardez les côtés ils sont
vie les nigauds lui attention mathieu
mathieu et je vous jure juste petite
honda comment vous trouvez que ça lui va
mettre à nu et ça lui met en valeur
novateur ça très chaud flottant et
berlin c'est moderne
[Applaudissements]
aulas alors il est où le nom mais pas
ses beaux cheveux super bien simple on
me fait une vraie couleur faut tout
recommencer
mais non c'est très beau je vous jure
que c'est vrai elle a fait ressortir tes
yeux vous trouvez voilà mais je tombe
tout le temps dans le piège dans le coup
alors laisser mourir chez nous mais
franchement c'est vrai tu es vraiment je
vous jure shoota se trouve ça super beau
je trouve très très beaux messieurs vous
asseoir
benoît benoît toi qui est dégueulasse et
de lui avoir fait remplir le jeu reste à
des 8es mathieu giroux jurques et je
vous jure que c'est là qu'on va donner
un très vilain est ce que ça vous va
bien nous tient sur twitter http
chauveau aubergines
s'il vous plaît les chéris c'est très
réussi bravo mathieu donc voilà je vous
le dis bon mathieu bravo et benoît
benoît est ce que ce que ça s'en va bah
non c'est permanent tu m'as dit faire
une permanente non alors ça rigole à 90
s'attendre à passer une couleur
permanente
maurice charrier comment il s'en
charrier mes vraies couleurs de
l'ammoniac étouffé oui c'est bien là
tout c'est pas cool rc et permanent ça
reste il y pousse il pousse en moyenne
les miens d'un centimètre et demi par
mois
là il m'a fait quoi là j'ai de moi j'ai
30 ans je vous le jure m'a tuer que je
vous trouve magnifique superbe mélodie
mais sur glace à vous faire une couleur
dans combien de temps a maintenant la
faut laisser reposer les cheveux sinon
elle va péter au bac il va être chaud
donc qu'est ce que vous voulez ou pas
miss mauritius vous savez bigou choisir
nous les fusées l'examen ben oui lemon
attention je vous jure que ça vous va
super bien si je vous jure les filles
franchement c'est pas tout à fait un
carton il faut voir le public par match
shaima pas dégueu rockstar avec main
avec le cube rouge de la semaine ça va
le faire
qu'est ce qui se passe car le pubis
maintenant demain je déjeune avec mon
père qui est avocat et je déjeune avec
lui juste en bas de son cabinet
d'avocats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jo lang son agent ce mec voilà bonjour
je vous aime matthieu delormeau
voilà tout le 10 baguettes vous êtes
serait sinon bien mais si vraiment vous
êtes un génie
bravo merci je laime très fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]